Crocs endorsement happened yet it's on
the way they got it man it's on the way
hey are you still hanging on the Android
you are huh yeah come on man this guy
it's on the way this guy hey man it's on
the way yo and Samsung [__] take care
of this guy right he's got the green
bubbles all day right and it's real so I
wanted to ask you cuz um there I I I'd
love to see a couple of things one I
think we have a mutual friend who I
talked to today one of my closest
friends in music industry Simba who I
love dearly and um you know he's he's
he's in the major label machine you know
as he is um uh so I don't know how easy
or hard or difficult it is for you guys
to drop a real project together um but
I've heard that being floated around I
feel like when I think about the two
guys not just in the bay I'm talking
about just music period where I'm just
like man we're in good hands it's you
and him at the top of that list was that
something you guys have talked about or
is that something that not really uh not
really we don't need me and Simba um
like hell of a feeling is like our first
song together like we worked on some
[__] prior but it wasn't nothing we both
love hell of a feeling was our first
track together we never really anytime
we link we don't do music like we really
hang and chop it up or it come to the
backyard and we rap like man that's the
dope thing about like bro I [__] with
nigg you got to be human with me like
like con is one of my my best friends
and it's like we come we don't even do
music together we just rap and hang and
chill and talk about life I think Simba
2 has got an understanding of a lot of
things out like that at a high level
that most artists don't in terms of like
branding in terms of like how he speaks
in terms of like when he goes on
platforms I think he sometimes he'll
approach an interview like it's an album
yeah Simba Simba's Simba's uh smarter
than a lot of
um a lot of the [__] in the game like
he's just more strategic and calculated
he understands what about you doing an
album Nothing But pilo beats it's coming
we are me me and P been talking about
that for the past two years so yeah
that's has to happen right cuz dog the
listen you you and you over just pilo
beats for a whole project right and then
[__] be a moment too for the for the
for the home team man and that'll shut
up some of the uh the you know the the
Bay Area Gatekeepers get that won't even
shut them up there's nothing that could
shut them up it's like I made baggage
claim in the whole world that [__] was
going viral for months T 20 like that
nothing to shut them up you know that
just doesn't happen I've reached a
million followers independently and I've
never bought a follower that's beautiful
there is nothing that could shut these
people up cuz they don't know nothing I
don't buy streams every I have organic
authentic growth are you still um so for
people who don't know who maybe are just
heard of you watching this you have a a
situation with your albums where well
one what I love that you do is you take
care of your team so if someone shoots a
video if you do a a full project with
you know your producer uh you're cutting
the team in on the on the on the equity
on the album right um are you still
doing that in terms of like fans being
able to say man I want to get a cut sell
stock every month and is that stock walk
me behind the business behind that
because um for people who don't know
there's a there is a platform that's
called Dro kid right where you're able
to upload your music uh and then split
the music which is an easy way for you
to pay featured artists writers
producers management whatever right so
are you Distributing the stock it gets
purchased and then do you go in on is it
Dro kid
I don't use disc kit anymore like the um
the technical capability wasn't there
for the level that I was doing it at so
I currently use uh command shift Nvidia
and I just start heard I just start
rocking with two loss as well I like
they they're back in yeah I heard VI is
dope yeah video is great command shift's
great I and these are drro companies
that are similar to like toon C these
are distribution companies and they have
the same type of Technology but at a
larger scale term that been my thing
like man there's other dealings that we
were trying to do but it didn't align CU
they didn't have a split system and to
me it's like if I can't split the money
and control my own back end and see
where my [__] going and when I want to
pay somebody that's a red flag it just
doesn't it's also if you don't have the
split system set up and you're a Dro
company I mean how I mean tonor had to
do it right eventually right Tor didn't
do it for a long time they didn't do it
for a long time came to do they
understood that's like well [__] I mean
shut out the Dr kid cuz they changed the
game for real you don't have one you're
encouraging people to steal money from
other collaborators and artists yeah
because you might not even want to do it
on purpose especially because there's
different angles of that but let's say
you're an artist just the idea of like
maybe you have management that's
supposed to handle the splits and you
know it's it's just it things get lost
in the wind if you could just set up the
splits and it's just locked in man I
just started using two losses portal
recently and I got to go holl at at them
because they got it set up to where you
submit the release then you enter the
split and I'm just going to tell them
the same thing like you're going to
encourage people to be able to monetize
their art before they start paying their
collaborators like you not you shouldn't
be able to submit the release until
everybody is kind of accounted for and
because not not you not me but a lot of
artists A lot of people it's like human
nature that like once you see that money
come in you're like hey boy it's tough
but but what I'm saying is like if you
just set up the splits from the jump
then whatever money you're getting is
the money you're getting you need to
exactly and then you're like cool you
know what I mean but if you get the
whole pie and you're like yeah you know
some people are inclined to be a little
little cheaper right right naturally
that's a human thing um